Hello and welcome to this video. We're now going to be talking a little bit about state trees
before we jump into the next exercise. So what are state trees? Well the state trees is a
state machine system which allows us to replace the entire behavior tree. So it is
a different method of firing up different tasks and controlling how the AI will function
within the world. State trees are relatively newer than behavior trees and they're where
most of the effort is being made at Epic in forms of development. They've got some
specific advantages and we'll talk about them as we're going on, but it is sort of recommended
that unless you're working with older versions that you look at state trees. They can do
everything that the previous behavior trees can do, but they've got some added functionality.
So before we go across, let's talk about some of the classes. The behavior
tree is going to be the equivalent of the state tree. Services can be replaced by a number
of things, but global tasks is what you would usually use to replace the services.
Blackboard. Blackboards are going to be replaced by bound variables, and this I think is one of
the bigger advantages of the state tree, but you don't have to have this whole passing data
in and out of the blackboard in order to control the flow. Now decorators. This is probably
where the biggest change is. We have something that's called entry conditions and transitions,
and these are going to be what controls how we move through the state tree. So we'll go over
those in detail as we're doing the exercise. Now why would you use a state tree?
There are a number of different reasons, but they generally break down into these. The first one
is it is a more controllable transition. Now we're in a behavior tree. You've noticed that we
have to stop people going down certain paths, and it needs to evaluate the entire behavior tree
whenever you're going back to scratch and figuring out what to do. We don't need to do
that with state trees. In state trees, we can directly transition between any state,
and we do this just by controlling the transitions and the entry conditions.
Next up, it is not necessarily tied to an AI controller. With a behavior tree,
we have to have an AI controller. It's built around that class structure. However,
a state tree can be tied to any actor, realistically speaking. It's often used,
for example, to create doors that might have different states and function in different ways,
depending on if they're open, closed, or smashed down, or so on. So it is useful beyond
AI control. Finally, performance. Most of the development that we're doing now is going into
state trees, and just because it doesn't need to re-evaluate everything from scratch,
state trees will tend to be more efficient. Now again, this is depending on how you write them,
but in general, they are a more performant option. So that would bring us to the end
of the theory on state trees. In the next videos, we're going to go about
building a state tree setup from scratch.